i'm delighted to be here at the opening
of five new flats on the team bridge 100
program this brings our total to seven
which is a start of build delivering 100
new homes for local residents
what this really means is that people
who are in temporary accommodation have
now got a permanent place to live and
we're seeing that right now as people
are moving in and we're handing over the
keys to people who are delighted to have
a safe secure home that they can live in
this is a beginning to helping to cure
the housing crisis that we have here in
team bridge we have a thousand
households on the waiting list today
there's five fewer it's not enough but
it's a start we've got three upstairs
flats which are a mixture of different
sort of
sizes and we've got two flats on the
ground floor that's specifically built
for people uh in wheelchairs um and
we've got disabled parking spaces here
we've got electric car charging points
out here so things can be charged up and
all of the inside area on the ground
floor is easily accessible whether
you're in a chair or whether you have
mobility problems
delivering that in a new build is so
much more straightforward than trying to
adapt an existing house and that is
better for the residents and it's better
for team bridge as well because it's a
cheaper way of providing a better
facility so it's a win all round these
houses are affordable to rent and
they're affordable to heat we've got
underfloor heating which is run off air
source heat pumps that means that there
are no radiators on the wall that means
you've got more usable space it means
you've got a flat that is lovely and
warm and the whole place just feels warm
we've got solar panels on the roof that
means your electricity is being
generated for free when we get this
right we will dramatically reduce the
amount of
power that you need to buy
and by having no gas in this building
there's no fossil fuel this has been
done as a low carbon development so
we're reducing the carbon that's going
into the house so we are doing
everything right for the environment and
providing a better place for people to
live what what do you think of it oh
it's fantastic it looks so nice big
breeze to me for about and it's really
comfortable it's pretty quiet so it's
nice it's fair enough
i feel the space in here
it's better for me so
i can do more for myself now i'm here so
that's good and i've got more
independence to do everything so
you know it'd be it make a good
difference yeah and get out much more
easier i haven't got a like
just like plan my day for when i can go
into town because i'm right in town so i
can say well i can pop into them today
so yeah
the other property i was in
was very cold damp um
no matter how much heating you got when
it was always cold it would be a lot
easier to try and like cook and access
everything without having to struggle
so and yeah i'm looking forward to all
that being more independent so cook and
see what we can do